c'est plutôt gentil ou plutôt cruel
en fait
j'aime bien j'aime bien les faire mourir
et puis voir les autres pleurer autour
je trouve ça marrant
on commence avec un CD-ROM plutôt
étonnant il s'agit des Sims des
personnages qui vont vite nous être
familiers effectivement ça tâche très
vite à ces personnages que l'on fait
vivre dans leur maison on pourrait dire
que ce CD-Rom utilise le principe du
Tamagotchi on doit s'occuper de nos Sims
chaque jour pour les faire évoluer dans
leur société à l'univers que je vous
propose de découvrir tout de suite
voici l'univers des Sims dans un cadre
de vie choisi par le joueur il peut à
loisir passer d'une maison à l'autre
d'une famille à l'autre pour faire vivre
ses personnages car ici pas de gagnant
ou de perdants on gère des vies humaines
virtuelles
et pour cela il faut commencer par créer
ces Sims prénoms personnalité physique
c'est au goût de chacun
[Musique]
les Sims ont tous leur centre d'intérêt
cette jeune femme par exemple M peindre
plus elle utilise son pinceau plus ses
qualités artistiques se développent et
influent sur sa vie future mais il ne
faut pas oublier d'équiper la maison les
Sims doivent se nourrir se laver décorer
leur intérieur en fonction de leur
budget qu'il ne faut pas dépasser bien
sûr allez une plante dans la chambre
c'est joli et ça ne coûte pas cher
ainsi va la vie des Sims que le joueur
accompagne au jour le jour sans fin il
serait intéressant d'effectuer dans
quelques temps une étude sociologique
l'utilisateur de ce CD-Rom va-t-il
reproduire sa vie ou bien sans inventer
une autre complètement différente
affaire à suivre mais même dans un jeu
le dur retour à la réalité des choses
existent après des moments forts
agréables à droite sur l'écran un
message de l'ordinateur rappelle que ce
personnage a un emploi et qu'il est
l'heure de partir décidément on n'est
jamais tranquille même dans un univers
virtuel la sortie aujourd'hui de sims 2
si vous ne savez pas de quoi il s'agit
demandez à vos enfants ils sont tiens
pas au courant Sims c'est un jeu vidéo
qui connaît un énorme succès en raison
de son originalité il ne s'agit pas de
tuer un ennemi imaginaire ou de marquer
des buts mais d'une simulation de la vie
la vie sociale professionnelle amoureuse
bref des rapports humains en France on
compte près de 2 millions de joueurs
Nicolas Châteauneuf Michael kARIO
sauver la galaxie à bord de votre
vaisseau spatial
enfreindre le code de la route sans
perdre de points sur votre permis autant
de possibilités incroyables offertes par
les jeux vidéo
mais ce qui marche le mieux en ce moment
c'est ça une simulation de la vie
quotidienne et de ses petits dérapages
sur ordinateur les Sims c'est le nom de
ces personnages virtuels qui nous
ressemblent tant depuis 4 ans ils ont
conquis la planète c'est le jeu vidéo le
plus vendu en France 38 millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde et
aujourd'hui sort un deuxième volet très
attendu un titre qui marche extrêmement
fort et qui représente la meilleure
vente sur le jeu vidéo depuis maintenant
deux trois années bon c'est un jeu qui
colle complètement au concept de la
téléréalité et c'est vrai qu'on fait une
mise en avant très importante avec
l'aide des fournisseurs les Sims une
poule au jeu d'or pour l'éditeur ce jeu
attire en effet un public très large
plus féminin que d'habitude et séduit
par une liberté d'action totale qui vire
parfois au sadisme à l'encontre des
petits personnages plutôt gentils ou
plutôt cruel
plutôt cruelle en fait
j'aime bien j'aime bien les faire mourir
et puis voir les autres pleurer autour
je trouve ça marrant
mais c'est vrai que plus on réaliste
plus plus on s'y attache et moins on a
envie d'être méchant avec des choix du
joueur dépendent en effet le destin du
personnage sa maison sa carrière ses
amis sa famille tout dépend finalement
de vous et de votre humeur et si
celle-ci est vraiment mauvaise une
possibilité brûler la télé de vos
créatures
[Musique]
avec modération quand même ils sont
venus ils sont tous là pour découvrir
les Sims 3 la troisième génération du
jeu vidéo le plus vendu dans le monde
sans 7 millions d'exemplaires connus
pour son fameux prisme vert des
privilégiés qui rencontrent même une des
conceptrices venus spécialement pour eux
des États-Unis ils sont vains amateurs
choisis pas du tout au hasard mais pour
leur implication dans la vie du jeu sur
internet avec leur site leur blog ils
peuvent représenter jusqu'à 400 000
internautes
bien sûr on va en parler on va on va
faire un petit un petit compte rendu
justement pour présenter un petit peu
tout ce qu'on a pu voir et apprendre sur
le jeu ici c'est une manière de
rencontrer les gens de partager aussi
une passion parce que on connaît pas
forcément les gens moi je connais pas
beaucoup de gens qui qui ont la même
passion que moi pour les Sims donc ça me
permet de partager avec eux en vrai les
Sims un jeu vidéo de simulation de vie
où l'on peut créer sa propre famille la
fait évoluer pour la promotion de la
nouvelle version la société américaine
électronic arts compte avant tout sur sa
famille de joueurs pas trop sur les
médias classiques les Sims un drôle de
succès économique 3 millions
d'exemplaires en France à ses débuts les
dirigeants prévoyaient pour l'Hexagone
c'est carrément planté carrément planté
si on regarde la population je reste
convaincu aujourd'hui bon on a vendu 107
millions de copies mais si on multiplie
le nombre d'utilisateurs par rapport aux
copies on doit être au demi milliards
d'individus qui jouent au sims dans le
monde donc c'est une communauté hyper
importante et sur laquelle nous
apportons une attention particulière et
encore une fois merci à eux tous d'être
ici aujourd'hui
c'est un peu comme les gens qui aiment
le sport vous pouvez rencontrer
quelqu'un lui dire c'était un match
incroyable et là on a la même chose
quelle est ta simulation favorite ton
personnage préféré c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on peut parler c'est une
passion partagée ça construit une
communauté
pour le public le jeu sortira début juin
il sera attendu et déjà connu
[Musique]